c'est une barre marc parent fait que
toblerone mister big
moi ca héros des pâquis quatre faces
marie sophie creps crunchy les cheese la
chocolat au lait des souvenirs d'enfance
seront faciles à manger aussi la
nostalgie est un très bon vendeur dans
les barres de chocolat caramel dans la
nomenclature des aliments réconfortants
vient toujours numéro 1 au numéro deux
jours dans le bel et spécialiste en
marketing et a consacré sa thèse de
doctorat au chocolat une industrie en
pleine santé
dans le cas des liqueurs douces des
boissons sucrées par exemple on a encore
des difficultés là aller chercher de la
croissance alors que l'on n'en parle du
5 et demi pour cent c'est à peu près 3.5
milliards de dollars par année
les marques sont sensiblement les mêmes
mais ce qui change ce sont les formats
la traditionnelle barre d'environ 45 g
reste toujours aussi populaire il vient
aussi la grande table est de 120 g
mais ce sont ces 5 min d'environ 200
grammes qui depuis 2018 sont la tendance
les sacs c'est l'eau qui contiennent ce
qu'on appelle des mini boucher c'est le
secteur qui est en plus forte croissance
présentement dans cette catégorie là on
parle d'une croissance d'à peu près de
10% par année donc il ya beaucoup
d'argent et beaucoup de sous à faire
avec les 5 min on s'est aperçu que le
consommateur porte moyeux attention
quand ils grignotent comme ça on regarde
pas un conteur mental de tout ce qu'on a
mangé dans ce petit sac là et puis
finalement au final on consomme un peu
plus même son cloche chez la
nutritionniste stéphanie qu'on dit c'est
trop c'est un paquet de 210 grammes
alors qu'une barre de chocolat est
traditionnel à peu près 50 g donc c'est
à peu près parfois une barre de chocolat
donc sont passés au travers je n'aime
pas parler de calories et de matières
grasses la traditionnelle barre de
chocolat s'est aussi mise au goût du
jour
il ya quand même des variétés qui
changent on veut amener du chocolat noir
20 minutes du thé vert ou du match aller
des ingrédients comme ça un petit peu
plus funky qui visitent les barres de
chocolat traditionnelle et plusieurs
tactiques qui sont utilisés pour
justement favoriser l'expansion puis les
ventes la gourmette isation si vous
voulez c'est qu'on va essayer de faire
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus
paulinienne un petit peu plus haut de
gamme et là même ses grands industriels
or vont aller jouer dans cette halle là
c'est beaucoup plus de cerveau et c'est
vous le packaging
oui mais depuis quelques années on a
présenté la kit kat au chocolat noir
après son le décliner de toute façon
avec d'autres ingrédients pourquoi pour
s'accaparer plus d espace de tablettes
pour un petit peu joué des coudes avec
les compétiteurs faut savoir que c'est
des milliards de dollars en jeu avec
quatre grands joueurs là si on revient
aux friandises chocolatées
on a tout d'abord nestlé qui en 15 % du
marché ce qui est quand même pas rien
suivi de russie et de cadbury adams qui
ont chacun 1 13% et lindt 15-11 pour ça
alors tout sauf qu'il ya quatre grands
joueurs qui se séparent 52 50% du marché
de la friandises chocolatées
donc c'est des gros sous qui sont en jeu
les recettes de ces barres elles n'ont
pas beaucoup évolué
bon il ya des qualités de chocolat peut
être un petit peu meilleur comme la
ligne mais il ya encore beaucoup d'huile
de palme ou de palmiste dans ces
friandises chocolatées
on retrouve des matières grasses
discutable dans plusieurs de ces
friandises là bien sûr du sucre à plein
pot jeter aussi lieu des ingrédients
qu'on retrouve dans toutes les barres de
chocolat comme la lécithine de soja de
santé j'ai entendu que le chocolat noir
stam europe j'aime bien donc le chocolat
noir
pour ce qui est des vertus du chocolat
noir il faut aussi faire attention à
toutes ses prétentions qui circulent
allègrement les études sur le chocolat
noir mais on utilise la fève de cacao et
du chocolat noir pur ce ne sont pas des
friandises chocolatées alors du chocolat
noir le même si un petit peu dans le
succès dans la danse c'est pas ça la
raison pour manger du chocolat ça
demeure seulement une question de
plaisir
donc les gens qui mangent du chocolat
noir parce qu'ils forment plus santé je
pense que ce n'est pas un argument
valable autre élément aussi c'est que on
retrouve beaucoup de science qui financé
par l'industrie du chocolat ça veut pas
nécessairement dire que les études sont
pas bonnes mais il faut rester critique
parce que ce qu'on constate de façon
générale c'est quand la science est
financé par l'industrie
mais on a souvent des résultats plus
positifs sur la santé que si c'était une
étude qui est sans conflit d'intérêt
maintenant
ce n'est pas tant le chocolat noir qui
préoccupe corinne voiliers de la
coalition poids
ce sont surtout des stratégies marketing
des géants du chocolat pour rejoindre
les enfants nettement avec la coved 19
quelque chose qui nous inquiète c'est
que on passe un peu plus de temps
l'effet d'attentes sont plus longues de
plus en plus de commerces moi même nous
faire sillonner à travers des allées de
bonbons de chocolat au grand dam des
parents oui un placement qui agressif
pourquoi on profiterait pas de
l'occasion pour mettre des fruits et
légumes aux 15 pour ce site est plutôt
un achat plus santé ça permettrait aussi
de relancer notre économie favoriser les
produits locaux d'issy encourager nos
marchés au royaume-uni récemment elles
ont adopté un plan d'action pour réduire
l'obésité et ils ont mis en place de
plusieurs mesures dont l'interdiction de
vendre des produits riches en sucre en
sel et en gras aux 15 dans d'autres
endroits stratégiques dans les commerces
la promotion des deux coureurs dans les
circulaires d'épicerie et de pharmacie
est aussi devenu monnaie courante
le royaume-uni a aussi mis en place
l'interdiction de faire des rabais deux
courants sur ces produits longs une
autre mesure qui serait très favorable
pour la santé qu'on pourrait avoir
réussi et j'ai aussi vu qu'il y avait
des mesures sur les logos simplifiée sur
le devant des emballages qui permettrait
d'identifier rapidement si un produit
est riche en sucre en sel ou en gras
pour nous permettre de faire des choix
plus sains le gouvernement libéral s'est
engagé à mettre en place un étiquetage
simplifié
c'est aussi très réaliste de penser que
c'est quelque chose que le gouvernement
provincial pourrait mettre en place
appui à la calorie la dengue ou non mais
regardez 230 quelle horrible 42 ans
et celle à 200 calories pour 85 g
en attendant vaut mieux s'y faire et
consommer ces friandises chocolatées
avec modération
oui mais quand déjà on se déculpabilise
de manger du chocolat
déjà on va manger moins souvent parce
que quand le mange on la prie si c'est
sûr que le chocolat c'est pas un aliment
du quotidien c'est une gâterie dans le
créneau de la friandises chocolatées
on y voit généralement pour le goût pour
le roi pour la satisfaction à gauche
le reste on l'oublié un peu saisis
bonbons beau et bon